Es ist ein ungewöhnlicher Anblick:
Rote Amerikanische Sumpfkrebse bevölkern
die Wege im Tiergarten - mitten in Berlin.
Direkt am Brandenburger Tor beginnt der
große Park.
Wie genau die Krebse hierherkamen, ist
unklar.
Vermutlich stammen sie von
Aquarienbewohnern ab,
die jemand hier ausgesetzt hat.
Seit 2018 sorgt Klaus Hidde dafür,
dass die Sumpfkrebse in den Berliner
Gewässern nicht überhandnehmen.
Jedes Jahr zwischen Ende April und Anfang
November bringt er seine Reusen aus.
Wir sind in der absoluten
Innenstadt von Berlin,
und da ist Folgendes eingetreten:
Da ist ungefähr vor vier oder fünf Jahren …
sind die Krebse … ist also aufgefallen,
dass die Krebse sogar über die Wege hier
gelaufen sind.
Seitdem sind die Sumpfkrebse zu einer
wahren Plage geworden.
Die Allesfresser vermehren sich rasant und
bedrohen so andere Arten.
Außerdem sind sie als Träger der Krebspest
bekannt.
Auch hier im Britzer Garten, im Süden
Berlins, haben sie sich ausgebreitet.
Wir fangen in ’ner Woche im Tiergarten und
Britzer Garten …
fangen wir ungefähr 70 Kilo Krebse
zusammen.
Und 70 Kilo Krebse sind ungefähr 2.500
Krebse.
Also, das ist schon ’ne ganze Menge.
Mit seinem Fang beliefert Klaus Hidde
verschiedene Berliner Gastronomen.
wie das Restaurant „Fisch Frank“ im Westen
der Stadt.
Gekochte Sumpfkrebse stehen hier
regelmäßig auf der Speisekarte.
Die Krebse sind einfach sehr beliebt,
weil sie neu sind.
Die Leute kennen hier nur die Flusskrebse.
Diese Sumpfkrebse sind ’n bisschen anders.
Die schmecken vielleicht ’n klein bisschen
süßlicher, nussiger.
Und [das] ist interessant, das ging viel durch
die Presse,
und jeder möchte eigentlich mal diesen Krebs
gegessen haben.
Die Sumpfkrebse werden in einem würzigen
Sud gekocht.
In das kochende Wasser kommen ein
Lorbeerblatt,
Salz, Kurkuma und Pfeffer, geraspelte
Karotten und Koriander.
Anschließend bleiben die Krebstiere für fünf
Minuten im Topf.
So, dann nehmen wir den Krebs,
und dem dreht man so ein bisschen den
Schwanz raus,
und dann kann man von der Unterseite
den Panzer wegdrücken.
Und dann haben Sie nur noch das
Schwanzsegment
- oder machen ihn eben ganz raus -
und hat das reine Krebsfleisch, was man, was
man dann essen kann,
und in dem Fall ist das meins.
Die Krebse werden mit Salat, Baguette und
Aioli serviert.
Auch in der gehobenen Gastronomie sind die
Sumpfkrebse angekommen,
wie hier im „Mrs. Robinson's“ im Stadtteil
Prenzlauer Berg.
Inhaber Ben Zviel bereitet die Krebstiere mit
Koji zu, einer Sauce aus fermentiertem Reis.
Wir verwenden hauptsächlich lokale Produkte
aus biodynamischem und biologischem
Anbau.
Und Koji ist eine wirklich gute Basis, um diese
Aromen aufzunehmen
und ihnen eine weitere Dimension zu
verleihen.
Doch zunächst werden die Sumpfkrebse
gegrillt.
Koji-Sauce, braune Butter und Zitrone geben
dem Gericht eine besondere Note.
Wir leben in einem Gebiet
mit Süßwasserfischen,
und es gibt nicht viele Krustentiere
im Süßwasser.
Die Sumpfkrebse sind eigentlich das einzige
Schalentier, das man hier bekommt,
das vielleicht an Garnelen oder Langusten
erinnert.
Rote Amerikanische Sumpfkrebse in Berlin:
eine Plage, die zur Delikatesse wurde.